(soft somber music)
- [Narrator] When the
coronavirus first arrived
in the United States, few
places were hit as hard
as nursing homes, and few
nursing homes were hit as hard
as the Menlo Park Veterans Memorial Home
in central New Jersey.
A "Wall Street Journal"
investigation found
that nearly 100 people
died at Menlo in April,
more than 10 times the
number in a typical month.
A spokesman for the state
agency that runs Menlo
declined to respond to most
of the "Journal's" questions,
citing expected litigation, but in August,
reporter Chris Weaver
interviewed Vietnam veteran
and surviving resident Glenn Osbourne
to understand more about what happened
to the residents of Menlo Park.
- Now that we're nearly six months out
from the beginnings of the pandemic,
do you feel like you know the status
of all the residents who you
knew before the outbreak began?
- I would say 85% I know.
There's a few I don't know
and I would like to know
of a couple residents
that I knew socially where they are.
Recently, even though I'm
not supposed to wander out,
I've gone out and I would find them.
They're so weak.
They can hardly talk.
And they're so pale and they're not moving
and they're still trying to
recover from this disease.
It's a horrible thing to see.
- [Narrator] Among the dead
were 84-year-old Isabella Kovacs
and 86-year-old Joan Williams.
Their stories provide a window
into what went wrong at Menlo Park.
(soft piano music)
The Menlo Park Memorial Veterans Home
accepts veterans, their
spouses, and Gold Star parents.
It has 312 beds in six residential units,
all with patriotic names:
Stars and Stripes, where
the dementia patients lived,
and Freedom, where Joan lived.
Joan moved to Menlo in 2015.
She was elected to be representative
to the resident council
for about three years running.
- She would travel up and down the hallway
of Freedom, talking to the residents,
asking what is their concerns?
Heh, that can go on for a
half hour at a time sometimes.
- We would go to visit her
and even family members of other residents
knew my mother on a first name basis.
She always had her makeup
together, her hair done,
and you know, just a classy type of lady.
- [Narrator] Isabella
Kovacs arrived at Menlo Park
in January 2020.
She had served in both the
Army and the Air Force.
- Like Joan, she was in the Freedom unit.
- Once we got here, they had a welcome,
a little room that had a big sign
that said welcome on a chalkboard
and they had a balloon for her
and they brought us all beverages
and offered us some lunch.
- [Narrator] But she would
have little time to settle in.
Not long after Isabella
arrived, there was an outbreak
in the Life Care Nursing
Home in Kirkland, Washington,
and soon after, the coronavirus
began spreading rapidly
in nursing homes around the country.
Still, Menlo was caught
flat-footed by the outbreak
and the administration's best attempts
to mitigate the spread fell short.
They created a quarantine
area for COVID patients
within the Alzheimer's
unit, Stars and Stripes.
It was separated from the rest of the unit
with a plastic tarp.
And the home resisted other
more obvious safety measures.
- One of the things that
we keep hearing about
is that the staff weren't
wearing protective equipment
all the time and, in
fact, that it sounds like
the administration might
have instructed them not to
for some reason.
- Yes.
I actually witnessed senior administration
physically remove the protective equipment
from the storage cabinet.
They were said, "We
don't want you to wear it
because you'll frighten the residents,"
and that frightened me more than anything.
- [Narrator] Staff members
claim they were not allowed
to wear masks outside the quarantine unit.
A March 27th email from
the New Jersey Department
of Veterans Affairs to Menlo's CEO
outlined the escalating consequences
for mask insubordination, oral counseling,
written warning, official
reprimand, and suspension.
Menlo spokesmen declined to comment,
but Brigadier General Mark Piterski,
who was deputy director
of the agency at the time
but has since retired, said
masks were in short supply
and the agency was following
federal guidelines.
Joan and Isabella's story takes
a turn in the end of March.
- I spoke to her on a regular basis.
I spoke to the nurse supervisor.
She was doing fine. She was doing fine.
- [Narrator] On March 30th,
Menlo resident Rose Dente
tested positive for the
virus at an emergency room
at a nearby hospital.
She died the next day.
The virus was inside Menlo Park,
but the administration didn't
tell residents' families.
- April 3rd is when I lost
communication with my mom.
The 4th, still can't
get in touch with Mom.
The 5th, can't get in touch
with the nurses' station,
can't get in touch with Mom.
- [Narrator] Joan was
somewhere on the Freedom unit.
A few days after Sheri lost track of her,
she was put into room 239
alongside Isabella Kovacs.
- It was obvious by
then Joan was very sick.
She was asleep all the
time and they were in there
checking her temperature
all day long she said.
The staff wouldn't tell me anything.
- [Narrator] but in an April 6th email,
the home's CEO, Elizabeth Schiff-Heedles,
asked for permission to tell residents
and their family members
that COVID was spreading.
The next day, April 7th,
she mailed that letter,
but more than a week
after the first resident tested
positive for coronavirus.
It was too late for Joan.
She was transferred to Room
753 in Stars and Stripes
and, later that night, to the hospital.
- Mom tested positive for COVID.
Her lungs were in very bad condition.
So it was like a perfect storm.
- [Narrator] Back at Menlo,
Isabella was getting sick.
She, too, was transferred
somewhere in Stars and Stripes.
- I asked three different staff members
if they were gonna test her for COVID
and all three said, "We
don't test for COVID here."
On April 12th, well into
the outbreak at Menlo,
the New Jersey Department of
Military and Veterans Affairs
posted this video on Facebook.
It shows the staff and CEO
of the home, Schiff-Heedles,
dancing in the hallways
in an apparent effort
to raise the residents' spirits.
Menlo declined to comment.
- They trying to say
they're trying to cheer up.
I was in shock.
They were dancing in the hallways
where, literally, the residents were dying
in the rooms that they were passing by.
- [Narrator] Plastic sheets
separating Stars and Stripes
from the rest of the facility was sagging.
Staff members in full
PPE went back and forth
across the partition.
More and more residents
were being shuffled throughout the home.
Isabella was sent to the
emergency room on April 17th
and also tested positive for COVID.
She and Joan were dying.
- They let me go on up.
I put on two masks and a face shield.
I had two pairs of gloves.
I told her about heaven
and I listed the names of
everybody she's gonna see again.
I told her that she was the best mother
I've ever could have had
and how much I loved her
and that she's gonna get this mask off
and she's gonna fly free.
And I couldn't stay in there
that long because I was just,
I didn't want her to just hear me cry.
I was just trying not to.
- And then the nurse knocked on the door
and I told her, I said, "Mom, I love you."
And that's the last (sniffles)
that I was with my mother.
- Unfortunately, both passed away
within a couple of days of one another.
I wanted to share those details with you
only because it does seem like,
you know, her particular path,
- Path.
- kind of covered some of the same ground
that we were speaking
about generally earlier.
- Means a lot to me. I appreciate it.
Thank you.
- [Narrator] Joan Williams
died on April 21st.
Isabella Kovacs died on April 23rd.
Their families are among those
that have begun the process
of suing the agency that runs Menlo.
The agency reported just 62
deaths in its official tally.
A spokesman said that count
is based on experts' conclusions
and that the agency mourns the loss
of every veteran at its facilities.
But dozens more died
with COVID-like symptoms,
according to internal patient records.
Many of those residents were never tested,
their families say.
The New Jersey Department of Health
ultimately confirmed the
"Journal's" findings,
revealing another 39 probable
COVID deaths at Menlo.
- I have lost more friends,
more good veterans,
than I did in the war and combat.
These are true heroes.
They fought for America.
They were wounded soldiers and came back,
came back from World War
II and Korea and Vietnam,
only to be left here and
treated with indignity,
not cared for, not protected.
(soft somber music)